you mentioned in the book that
professional writers know how to take a
story idea and make it commercial so how
does an amateur writer develop this
skill you know several of the writers
said you know I had no formal training
and writing I just locked myself in the
room when I watch sitcoms and I'm sort
of an analytic type and I just figured
out how they do it and it was
interesting that they were pretty much
self-taught David breckman who who's his
brother created monk and it was on monk
for many years ever that live before
that David is young he's 40 he's very
young just a kid and um he he wishes he
was 24 again he he learned from his
accounting he just was in love with
every aspect of the business and studied
everything and and still yeah and the
thing he said and then he tells his
students cuz he's teaching now is expect
for your first couple of scripts to be
really lousy and be happy about that
embrace that because that's you learn
much more this is what I would tell the
I I don't like the word amateur but this
is what I would say to a beginning
writer embrace crap embrace it allow it
to be bad because that's the way you
learn you don't learn from writing
something good nobody does that's
another one of those myths that's out
there the idea that a lot of young
writers think oh I do one or two drafts
and I've done my job but but real
professionals know that it's 14 15 16 17
drafts you know and that you and that
you'd be concentrating on different
things in each draft but that's the
hardest thing I have to do with students
is say to them start do it again do it
again you know there's some good stuff
in here you're not telling the story you
think you're telling and they get so
down on themselves when it doesn't come
out perfectly in the first
and there is no perfection ever and any
professional writer will tell you that
that there's its net it might be great
but you take any great film that you can
think I'll just think of King's Speech
which i think is arguably one of the
best films in the last five years that
started as a play which he had put away
because the Queen asked him to you know
that story right she had asked him not
she'd want to
she said not while she was alive you he
he was doing a reading at some Little
Theatre in London and the directors
mother brought him and said you have to
make this you have to film this you know
it's weird the way things happen and you
know and he's not a young guy either
that that writer so I don't think there
are any rules again it's it's the it's
patience Joyce Carol Oates is one of my
favorite novelist said that the
difference between an amateur writer and
a professional is that she talked about
herself she said that when she starts
writing so this is good advice I think
for beginners that it'll take four or
five weeks and if she goes to the desk
every day the book will start to form
but you've got to go every single day
and show up even if it's for two or
three hours and what happens with
beginners is they don't they give up
around week three and they think it's
not gonna come you have to tolerate the
frustration you have to tolerate the bad
writing you did and this goes back kind
of to what I get out of this partnership
Peter is very very good at slinging
things up against the wall and and
letting it be whatever it is I he's very
fast and I am it's like dental surgery
for me the first draft I would probably
rather have a root canal than write a
first draft it's very hard but he gives
me something to look at it's much easier
for me
to come in and say okay well this could
go here or maybe I am just some people
just love writing first drafts and some
people hate it I hate it I love
rewriting hate writing he loves the
first draft he just loves riding it and
he doesn't judge himself he just throws
it out there that's one of things I hate
most about it it's but it's a it's a
gift to have that and why would I want
to be with someone who was like me you
know he also can put pressure on me he
likes that because he's Jewish and he
likes to sling guilt so it works well
for both of us I know a lot of joint
locks that comes in very handy he has a
here's a belt he's gonna be frightened
to Peter but I actually think that
that's really good advice for young
writers is to stay at the desk just stay
there
and no matter it's not about how fast
you're doing it it's about staying there
she's absolutely right choice Carlos
it's about allowing it to be crap
there's a term in psychology called
self-efficacy and whatever the hell that
means
it's we define it simply as
domain-specific self-confidence which is
equally annoyingly which is if you think
I'm handsome bossy when Jeffrey sits
down to write he'll stay at the task
because he knows if he doesn't long
enough it's gonna become okay but if
somebody doesn't believe in their skills
and they keep going back and saying I
don't like what's happening here it's
easy to get discouraged to say I don't I
can't do it so in English this project
doesn't work so I'm gonna start
something else so here's a good solution
for that for beginning writers and for
any writer is don't be attached to it
and don't go back I have to keep saying
this to students
you've got notes put them somewhere
don't go back and rewrite the first 25
day just keep going forward going back
is a trap Richard Walter talks about
this in one of his books going back in
the middle of a draft is super
because then you just keep your doing
what he's saying if your you're never
gonna finish it he's just always gonna
be it's much better to throw it up
against the wall let it be what it is
because then you've got something and
you can rewrite it and I I mean simple
and it seems obvious but you'd be
surprised how many writers won't do that
even seasoned professional when I meet
people who say I've been working on a
screenplay for 10 years I'm thinking I
always think to myself and they get a
tall star you don't get to you know that
you're not writing war and peace it's a
screenplay you should be writing you
know if that's what you're really doing
you should be writing five bad ones the
first five years you know not one for 20
years I mean that's crazy
you